in school I learned the trigonometric
functions kind of like this you have a
right angle triangle an angle typically
called Theta here mathematicians love
Greek letters and you label the sides
opposite adjacent hypotenuse then you
have the famous formulas sine equals
opposite over hypotenuse cosine equals
adjacent over hypotenuse and tan equals
opposite over adjacent so in 20 years of
development even in graphics work I
think for me this triangle has come in
handy close to zero times so instead
another way of visualizing this is to
start with a circle and to simplify
things further we can use one with a
radius of exactly one that is any point
that lies here on the circle is at a
distance of exactly one from the center
typically this angle here between our
vector and the x-axis Theta is expressed
in degrees ranging from 0 to 360. but
apparently this this is some arbitrary
system left over from well they're not
quite sure but if you think about the
circumference of a circle that's defined
by 2 times pi times the radius r with a
radius of 1 that boils down to just 2
times pi so instead of degrees if we
started at the x-axis here and moved one
unit of distance along the circle we
could invent a new unit for angles all
the radian so now we express angles in
terms of distance along the outside of
the circle and thus a circle is 2 pi
radians instead of 360 degrees and
that's how radians are made now given
this point here on the circle it forms
an angle Theta and since the radius of
this circle is 1 the hypotenuse is one
so sine is just the distance here along
the vertical and that means that cosine
is just the distance here along the
horizontal and tan well if you extend
the line here from x equals 1 upwards
and you extend the vector forming your
hypotenuse out this way where the two
meet tan gives you this distance here
the distance from their intersection
down to the x-axis I never use this but
it's there as you move this point around
the circle we obviously expect cos Theta
sine Theta and tan Theta to change and
we can graph those changes so sine Theta
oscillates between one and negative one
as this Vector rotates the circle and
cos Theta oscillates in much the same
way but just slightly offset from sine
of theta 10 is interesting because at pi
over 2 and negative pi over 2 you can
see that tan Theta is undefined
hopefully now seeing this in action and
what tan really is the graph of tan
Theta makes much more sense why it kind
of freaks out at certain values this is
where it gets a little interesting if we
call this Vector a we know that cos
Theta is just the X component of this
Vector here on the unit circle or you
could say this in a different way a
slightly longer way of saying it is in
terms of the full Vector a it is a DOT x
times 1 plus a DOT y times zero 0 or
again now we can say in terms of both A
and B where you know the B Vector is
just the x-axis or one zero so it's a
DOT x times B dot X plus a DOT y times B
dot Y which is now defined in a more
mathematical way it has a name it's the
dot product
so the dot product of A and B is equal
to cos Theta which is just this
horizontal distance here if a and b are
unit vectors the more General equation
you were taught in school was that a dot
b is equal to the length of a times the
length of B times cos Theta so now it
might make more intuitive sense then for
y given any two unit vectors if we take
the dot product between them you get cos
Theta because if you were to rotate
these things around the circle until one
hits the x-axis and suddenly this is
just reduced to our simple distance
along the x-axis actual real proofs
exist with like real math and everything
this isn't one of them just a nice way
of visualizing things but this is also
why the dot product is used to get the
scalar projection of one vector onto
another
because that's all this distance is
so then how are these functions
implemented if you have a chunk of code
when you call your Hardware or Library
function for stuff like sign what kind
of math sorcery are they doing well
these tend to be computed in different
ways
various approximations have existed for
ages back in the 7th Century the Indian
mathematician vascara gave the following
formula which I'm not going to read but
it worked really well in the range of 0
to Pi giving an absolute error of like
0.0016
in-game development way back in the day
it was often acceptable to use something
called a lookup table
by pre-computing values and either
finding the closest match or linearly
interpolating between adjacent values it
was possible to use a relatively small
lookup table to get acceptable results
a lookup table with 512 entries might
have an error of around
0.0001 or 1 e to the negative 6. but
getting things super right in games
isn't usually critical no one's life is
on the line unless you're jigsaw so for
example you could use 16 values from 0
to pi over 2 and that gives an error of
.0014 but cache misses are expensive
these days so lookup tables aren't used
as often anymore if you were to compute
these trig functions directly the first
thought is a Taylor expansion and
courtesy of Wikipedia they look like
this which does the job nicely but a
common complaint with Taylor series is
that the error isn't uniform the error
scales the further you are from zero
better approaches have a general theme
they combine a whole bunch of ideas they
tend to do what's called a range
reduction followed by an approximation
and then a reconstruction step first off
looking at a sine wave you clearly don't
need to approximate from negative
Infinity to Infinity we already know
that it repeats after 0 to 2 pi
from there you can exploit symmetry this
half is really the same as this half
just upside down and this half of the
wave is really just a mirror of the
other side
so in reality you only need to
approximate a small portion so now you
have four identical quadrants for this
function just flipped and reversed so
given a point in any of these quadrants
you'd map it to a point in the first
then you may use a polynomial
approximation like the Taylor series we
just covered or something more advanced
like Minimax anyway you compute your
value
then you map it back into the
appropriate quadrant and voila you have
an idea of how your Hardware computes
the sine value
the sine function on the screen is
running the code you see on the left
Intel has a paper from like 20 years ago
which details how a lot of their trig
functions were implemented you can also
poke around the new C library and see
similar ideas in action if you can read
the code it's not the easiest to work
through
Robin green also has a nice write-up on
their blog as well which is linked in
the description
lastly this explanation is taken from an
up-and-coming mask Force I'm working on
it'll be available soon if you're
interested in more intuitive
explanations of trigonometry matrices
and math for game development check it
out until next time cheers